if you look at it from space the top of
the world the white ice acts like a
reflector like a mirror that sends back
sunlight and energy and heat back to
space that's what made the Arctic the
cooling system of the planet I was
walking with Leo on the edge of the sea
ice in the high Canadian Arctic and I
told him we will not be able to stand on
the frozen sea anymore in about 25 years
scientific projections are that by 2040
there's going to be almost no sea ice
left in the entire Arctic climate change
through warming and acidification is
affecting the entire ocean because of
that the Arctic is warming and melting
at the rate that is faster than anything
else we've seen before
all that white cap that expands in the
winter and contracts in the summer every
time is expanding less and shrinking to
a smaller volume
that means massive melting of glaciers
no more sea ice for all these animals
that depend on the sea is for the
survival like the seals and the polar
bears the populations are going to crash
for the rest of the planet the melting
of the sea ice is going to be associated
with more extreme weather events some
areas are going to experience more
flooding some areas are going to
experience more droughts so I don't
think we're going to be very happy with
the climate that's coming there is only
one thing that needs to happen to solve
the issue of climate change which is
reduced dramatically our carbon
emissions our carbon portion that's it
we need to move from a fossil fuel
dominated society to society where
renewable energies are more and more
dominant we cannot pretend that this is
something that somebody else in the
future will have to build with we have
to take action right now if we are to
preserve a beautiful and wonderful
planet that we will be very happy to
live in
you